[Music]
be advised possible cyber crime
activity section 9 is repeat all
pinged
C this is Major I'm on
site
I'm human I'm
Flor but I embrace
change and
enhancement now there's nothing I can't
do nothing nothing I can't know nothing
I can't
be I we need to listen to
[Music]
something
it's my four-year-old daughter the time
it took her to sing that lullabi she
learned to speak fluent French no that's
there's an echo box up here someone's
scanning data traffic let's see who's
worth this kind of
[Music]
surveillance accessing hotel security
network
got it 43rd
floor someone contacts president's staff
someone's watching him Dr Osman what is
it you want from us I think it's more
about what hanker robotics can do for
you 73% of this world is woken up to the
age of cyber enhancement really want to
be left behind my people Embrace cyber
enhancement as do I there's no one who
really understands the risk to
individuality
identity messing with the human
soul gentlemen excuse me I think you
have the
wrong hallway six men shots fired
section 9 ETA 2 minutes out major too
long I'm going
in
I've heard this speech before from your
competitors and now hanker robotics
serves it with milky
suck hey hey hey hey this is what I'm
talking
about
[Music]
shot me
[Applause]
no
help me please don't let me die who sent
you help me please answer me collaborate
with hecko robotics and be
destroyed
you have to
remember I saw someone down
there he wasn't human